I did go to college and then I went to
prison so I they kind of mix the two hi
I'm Tim Allen and I'm in my garage with
more cars than necessary I have a kind
of an eclectic collection I like
authentic American Motors I actually own
the actual cars that I had in my
collection as a kid
hey how'd you get in here Tim for
security I'm doing very well thanks for
inviting us over here you have a great
car collection right let's talk about
some of your cars we're standing by the
Cobra SC it's just a little 289 with
Weber's on and Hildebrand's and it's
like made out of like aluminum foil it's
so light
yeah but it's a wonderful car always
always loved cobras
this is a fun because it's a rat rod
which I like it's all patina'd it's a 50
Cadillac series 62 I'll baste it's a
it's a handful it's a big old steering
wheel but it's not bad
I get more thumbs up on this one when
I'm driving it I really do enjoy it
it seems like a fun car to drive like
it's got to be just for a float a Laker
car I run whiskey to Pasadena even
though it's legal it just feels good we
pay taxes on it there's nothing against
the logs it turns out that the alcohol
is in fact legal
this is a Ford and it's got a Lotus
engine in it it's got R it's real
four-wheel drive I drove this to home
improvement set one day and a cop pulled
me over he goes you know that's not do t
certified oh it really he said I could
take this so this is not a Kent I can't
do anything except do this we bought
this on an episode of home improvement
on the show in order to do continuity
had to build it in rebuild it this is
apartment together so many times this
has got original Flathead by motor city
flatheads it's a jewel that they it's
just it's a brilliant car early American
iron love this stuff
409 bubble-top literally a truck motor
in a big stick shift I just love this
whole era when everything was simple
there's a four-speed car yeah that's got
to be fun oh yeah this is this is a
great car
this is the transformer car if you
combine a 57 Porsche and a 71 Karmann
Ghia you get this so it's got a Porsche
- Porsche seats they're wider and longer
than v-dubs they're different than
Porsches in that in their dynamics and I
think they're gorgeous cars non-stop
people think I'm a classy guy if I Drive
this you are a class low yeah but I mean
women go yeah you most like symphonies
oh yeah you have a symphony and I like
children and this is this is everything
classic Carrera GT unmistakeably
probably the hardest car to drive in
here because this is like it is
literally a race car everything about
this in a design sense is gorgeous
everything Porsche did is porsche design
push a quality this porsche i love i
love it
i drove this pretty much for a year like
daily this is a nutty impala this is a
big twin cam 32-valve out of the old z
desi r101 i had two of these on the home
improvement days this is a terribly fast
car still a very fast does it stop oh
yeah big breaks on it I was old street
racer I know how to drag race I mean
maybe not well but I know how to go to
quarter mile and this thing will fry it
it is so fast Tim thank you so much an
absolute Treaty of such a great car
collection and great stories I love the
ones that you design I appreciate you
coming by and more than that I
appreciate you and leaving get rid of it
I'm glad I love show I don't draw this
place too many people and don't tell
anybody that you saw this to see more
episodes of car collectors subscribe to
GQ com